COLT MCANLIS: In this episode
of Cloud Performance Atlas,
I help some IoT devices find
their long lost friends.
Is friendship the best
configuration for performance?
Stay tuned to find out.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
One of the big challenges
with IoT devices
is that there's a
tendency for each device
to use a different
set of protocols
for communicating with
other devices around them.
This is where IOT
exchange comes in.
Their product is somewhat like
a dating app for IoT devices,
where a device can find other
local devices that communicate
on similar protocols.
Their system was running
on a federation of VMs
inside of Google Cloud
using persistent disks
to host relational databases
that they were using
to keep everything in sync.
Sadly, after some
profiling, they
realized they weren't getting
the performance they wanted out
of the disk itself.
Now, if you remember,
persistent disks
are the ones that
aren't physically
attached to your
host VM hardware,
and they come in two flavors--
standard and SSD, that each
one has their own performance
characteristics, which,
unsurprisingly, matters a lot
for your usage configuration.
Now, for persistent
disks in general,
performance scales as a function
of the size of the disk.
The bigger it is,
the faster it is.
We can see here that for a
standard persistent disk,
the IOPS and throughput
scale pretty well in relation
to the size of the disk.
SSD persistent disks
show the same behavior,
although the numbers are
significantly higher.
However, SSD
persistent disks also
have performance scale
with the number of the CPUs
that the VM has, or
as the [? docs ?] say,
"SSD persistent disk
performance scales linearly
until it reaches either
the limits of the volume
or the limits of each
Compute Engine instance."
Hmm.
Which was where the
IoT exchange folks
were running into trouble.
Their VMs didn't have
enough CPUs for the IOPS
they needed to their SSD PDs.
By moving them from 8
core to 32 core machines,
they saw their IOP
performance almost double.
You got to love it when
data saves the day.
If you'd like to know
more about today's topic,
check out the article listed
in the description below.
And don't forget to check
out the rest of our Cloud
Performance Atlas
content on YouTube,
because when it
comes to performance,
every millisecond counts.
[MUSIC PLAYING]